[Music]
[Music]
what's one thing about Kimberly that is
different in this movie that you were so
proud of you know what this a little
different I think you know these kids on
just one thing they're not just like one
stereotype
so it's interesting cuz Symphony
actually and the meaning of the movie
she doesn't she does something not great
that she regrets and I think that kind
of stands out because like kids are
being wise you know and it's about how
she kind of learns from that mistake and
that's not really who she is
like she's waste smarter than that but I
think that's what's different she's not
she's not um she's not perfect she
actually does something quite mean so I
think that's that's an interesting thing
to watch and see how she progresses and
sheís wedges she's where just it wasn't
a below graduation I was like what we're
you know we're chose it you mean like
wedgies yes she does well huh sometimes
there were wedgies no question and
you've what you mean like the pseudo
shoes yeah yeah I know look guys I'm
gonna be honest yeah I'm gonna level the
reason we have that is one of me and
Becky like Becky's like I mean I know
for book she's that she's a little
chicken I'm Rachel feel like it would
have looked really weird if we were just
all you know gotta give a girl some like
I give him some high data give him some
high even though I like never wear heels
me neither
[Music]